I don't know how everyone is out at 2:58
on a freaking Thursday and they have
money to get a seven dollar 50 cent
grilled cheese in a tie-dye shirt what
do you do what do you do hi I'm Kate I
am pleased single Los Angeles is very
hard for dating I really don't know if
it's just me or the city that I'm in so
I figured I'll go to different cities
and see if I'm more in dateable there
okay what are what are you what are you
looking for
now that you've done sandy right like
what what is your you're kind of like we
look for in profiles I look at they're
like a little funny like a funny ish
profile I like that I definitely look
for whether or not they have a weird
mirror selfie I've gone on dates in Los
Angeles I've gone on dates in San
Francisco next up we went to Portland
wanting to make the best use of my time
I started swiping on people in Portland
while I was still in LA this one is
sarcastic witty caring cuddler yeah no
he's a cuddler I will always wipe now if
you say your account aware that is gross
well creepy I feel like beveling needs
to give it so off we went to Portland
I'm hold myself off to a great start
we're gonna find love
[Music]
baby
[Music]
[Music]
totally this is a great date outfit is
the only thing no looks like I'm gonna
guard it I love it
you're in a garden going to garden I
think you have really cool like you're
the cool girl that I want to hang out
with thank you but Eli things turn a
page where it's very empty I'm like I'm
gonna go MC Hammer had a side gig we're
out of paint
then great anything else I mean you look
great I think you could still use some
accessories but I don't have any I had
to go through airport security I feel
like I hate digging but I I'm excited to
me I'm gonna go in thinking that we're
gonna be friends and then see if maybe I
want to make out with that friend the
way I look at it is if you had a bunch
of jelly beans and I don't like licorice
jelly beans right now my life is just a
jar full of licorice jelly beans and one
cherry jelly bean I'd be like oh hell
yeah it's on I'm gonna have that cherry
jelly bean now if a tutti frutti was
thrown into the mix I put the cherry
jelly bean to the side but I'm living a
life of liquors jelly beans and hoping
for a tutti fruity and there's a bunch
of there's a couple cherries here and
there but I'm just not willing to eat
the cherry jelly bean does that make
sense
hey how you doing good how are you I'm
Pete Moe TV of course she seems fun I'm
really interested to see how things go
I'm looking forward to it I didn't like
beer until I went to Europe sometimes I
wonder
I don't know a lot but I know it's
mostly always delicious
I usually just look for like the alcohol
content and feel like I guess I'll just
learn to like this one
Marley was pretty cool sold me on Marley
is that he had a Hawaiian shirt on in
his picture and I boy do I love Hawaiian
shirts and then he wore one to the date
so that was awesome
our first date was at a brewery tour
brewery tour the rumery
tour
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
only problem was a date with a recently
engaged couple who had gotten engaged
days before I plan on getting I'm
composing some point during the trip but
it was fourth of July at sunset
you crack or first dates are awkward
enough why not throw it all on there
just pepper it with all the awkward you
possibly can and beer the beer was a
nice touch but that would help
I love sour beer they got like sour beer
they love sour my favorite beer there's
a lot of small talk would you consider
the hotdogs of sandwich by definition I
think it's the sound by definition it's
a sandwich well what's the alternative
there's not a sandwich no it's a hot dog
it's a soda green to bring that
literally a sub sandwich but just turns
to things that are holding substance
that are also foods it's either or
thinking is a bread or one big piece of
bread with a slit so it's so it's both a
taco and burrito have no split that's
fair if you want to date in a group if
you're more comfortable with a group
dating situation maybe a tour would be
right for you just maybe it won't be
just you and another recently engaged
couple enjoy the rest of your time here
thank you
take care all right and I'll talk to you
later okay have a nice walk it was
really fun
she seemed like a person I would enjoy
getting to know or want to get to know
more first teachers are just difficult
consider the hot dog sandwich my second
date was with Alex this guy Alex and I
were talking and we liked some of the
same music and we were into the same
music in high school it I always think
is very interesting like who's dumb like
what music someone's into in high school
whenever I do tinder just look through
all the pictures read the bio really
quick I was like oh it's it's fun from
LA so I was like yeah you know swipe
oh he's originally from Nebraska the
only other person I know from Nebraska
is Lady Gaga I like her
I would like to preface this with I had
just got on a brewery tour I was tired
dating is hard and sometimes I'm really
big into meat I'm 50 I'm not ready to
date
I really like television that's like my
favorite thing was television it might
be because I'm sad in general it is
great I don't know yes do you like
neutral yes great if your dream guy
could be a show this doesn't mean it's
my favorite show my dream guy would
probably be new girl it's a nice warm
show kind of warm man kind of a movie
buff my first job in high school was at
I'm big Star Wars Game of Thrones
yeah she's Harry Potter then we started
talking about different fandoms and I'm
a big fan of Harry Potter and he really
likes Star Wars
totally all right I respect Harry Potter
did you watch organ robe one that's yeah
no I said I would
that was episode them
it's that roughly Robo long was these
spin-off to be died in Episode seven
correct and then I did not see her
what Row one you should see is very good
like a gin herself for her name
with her name in the movie is dinner so
it's is it really yeah
her name was gin gy on the Jetta
she wasn't in Jedi way wasn't she is not
a matter really I have no idea
so Kate's currently freaking out we're
out here shooting interviews with lovely
people and she's texting us furiously to
help her out but I kind of want to see
what happens and see what how we should
get that of it
[ __ ] you Eli you're really really rude I
didn't know the difference between
Episode seven and rogue one I'm not the
right girl for you Alex
I don't think it works I've never been
on a Saturday
well thank you for meeting me here all
right I'm gonna give you a hug now okay
I thought it went really well felt like
we had a lot to talk about the second
date went okay I like that he into
fandoms she has her fandoms I'm like
yeah it wasn't much of a mark or
anything I don't know I don't know if
I'm excited for the third date if you
don't have a connection with someone
either just don't go forward with it I
would have wasted his time to be honest
he already came all the way out there I
[Music]
just found out that Portland has the
most college-educated single women per
capita and I came to the wrong city
I came to the right city so our third
date was at Art uncorked we had like
active on dating apps we go through
phases yeah you'll get yeah and you'll
get it and redownload it a bunch of
times I thought she was cute I liked her
photos and her bio explained what she
was trying to do so you know I was like
that'd be cool experience you know being
on BuzzFeed lovely Galaxy image that was
gonna be super exciting the dating life
in Portland is very open very
open-minded I guess it's very weird too
there's a lot of hardcore hipsters and
you can never really know what to expect
I guess choose yes all right
I think first dates are always will
forever be awkward no matter who you're
with or where you go
think they're so awkward it's so hard to
watch these yeah it makes me question if
I ever want to date again
already I have a hard time talking with
people and getting intimate with them
just if no cameras are there obviously
cake don't do the show yeah no I know
but we did it anyway so that's just
where that's just what happened I'm just
being honest with you guys to get there
I gotta see it every art class I've ever
taken
well this is fun because what's actually
happening is that were just reaching
separate he's been drinking a lot of
wine I don't know this isn't reconize I
mean I would to free true you guys are
really going for the volcano that's all
on purpose
we nailing it right I think so you were
there oh you think I think it's about
texture yeah what we lack in precision
we make up for in a million
[Music]
well this is weird this is fun is good
both really bad at this yeah all right I
feel like the date went really well he's
really luck a lot of fun something new
I've never done before so I think we did
have a lot of things in common I would
probably go out on another date with him
realistically I feel like I'd be more of
a friend for Kate Lake with Kate just
seems like a funny person but I guess we
didn't really have more we didn't really
have a one-on-one you know I guess
connection what are you see this is why
I'm not good at dating I like came out
of a most out of all of them but I don't
like anyone Oh No
I'd say we could attack Portland up on
the list of places that I'm undateable
forlán was a pretty affordable City
wasn't really the city for me
they're super weird they like that
they're aware which is totally cool I
just didn't fit in I need a place with a
little bit more energy and excitement so
let us know where we should go next
please everyone say Nashville
[Music]
[Music]